in deze video
geef ik een paar tips over hoe ik mijn hbo
rechten propedeuse heb gehaald
in één jaar mijn eerste tip is om alle hoor
en werkcolleges bij te wonen
de opdrachten te maken en ook deze te herhalen
veel van de opdrachten die namelijk maakt
komen gewoon in het tentamen terug
mijn tweede tip is om oefententamens te maken
zo weet je wat voor vragen je kan verwachten
want vaak zijn de vragen soortgelijk in het tentamen
dus kun je alvast mee oefenen
en mijn derde tip
maak de tentamens gelijk de eerste keer
dus niet uitstellen
en mocht je een tentamen niet halen
ga dan naar de inzage
dan kan je gelijk zien wat je juist wel
goed hebt gedaan of fout hebt gedaan
en dan kan je voor de herkansing juist daarop focussen
mocht je nog vragen hebben over de propedeuse
of over hbo recht of de uni algemeen
laat het vooral weten en vergeet niet te volgen